Not as easy as I... remember.
I don't like this, Richard.
It's almost as if you can
almost see the spot.
This is something right here.
JAY ROSENBLATT:
The bullying incident happened
that Friday in fifth grade.
The more I dove into it,
the more upset I am
that I was involved.
Why didn't I say stop?
I have to speak
to my classmates,
whomever I can find.
RICHARD: I remember being
a bit of an instigator.
We all as a mass,
kept on running down the stairs
and surrounded him.
Kinda feeling guilty
to this day
that I did something like that.
Richard and I are here
to go to the 50th reunion
for grade school,
which is strange.
It's morphed into
a little more than that.
ROSENBLATT:
Why do you think kids
pick on weaker kids?
SPEAKER: It could be
a sixth sense or something.
SPEAKER 2: Now, I probably
was not brave enough back then
to say, "That's not fair."
SPEAKER 3: I remember the circle
and the chanting.
SPEAKER 4: Being a bully is one
of the most disgusting things.
SPEAKER 2:
I remember being really shocked
by that kind of behavior.
ROSENBLATT:
Everyone carries pain,
yet through that pain,
I can now see yours.